you sometimes you get close to being out
of control sometimes you're out of
control
well you just want a minute you don't do
it right things are gonna be real bad
that's pretty much what makes you really
fight
my name is Eric Scott I'm the go-fast
jetpack pilot
things are cool he's you're pretty loud
and then you know like that
it is a short flying machine 33 seconds
sexy the longest flying one that's
actually out there were working today
each of these machines is definitely the
evolution of this would be to find a
different fuel source and with that you
got a different definitely deal with the
different but the different power unit
as well which is probably a jet turbine
design we're actually developing one
right now it's the T 73 model he'll have
eight to ten minutes of flight time you
don't need a runway you can understand
in any spot takeoff you know I can find
these things indoors
you